Vladimir Putin has gone back to work one
day after an audacious attack on his
office we see him here talking to the
development minister at the Kremlin
Russia's traditional seat of power but
we now know it's not immune to attack
in what seems to be a spectacular
failure of security the complex was hit
by two drones but how did this happen
and who's responsible
Moscow has a special system called the
sa-22 to ward off attacks from the air
it provides a big defensive Shield as
represented by these concentric rings
with its weapons placed on top of
prominent buildings this one pictured on
the roof of the defense Ministry yet the
first drone hit the top of the Senate
building within the Kremlin complex
setting fire to part of the roof 15
minutes later the second skirts the
flagpole and detonates above the roof of
exactly the same building experts wonder
whether the defense Shield had been
switched off
the system of the sa22 that we've seen
deployed in Russia should be able to
engage targets up to four kilometers out
with the cannon and the fact that these
devices have got such so close to to the
current buildings themselves
um is actually uh quite surprising
the Russians rarely admit to security
blunders but they made this one public
the top talk shows discussing the
details although not sharing the footage
of the strikes
the president's spokesman Dimitri peskov
blamed it on Washington
Ukraine is carrying out America's plans
but he's released no evidence no
pictures of the wreckage
some think the Russians carried out this
attack themselves
this war is going badly for Putin on on
balance
um it's more likely that there are
Russian hands involved in this attack
than Ukrainian attacks the Ukrainian
president currently traveling through
Europe has denied all responsibility we
don't stage attacks in Russia says
velodimir zelenski although they almost
certainly do
trains and fuel Depots in Russia have
been attacked over the past few days
including three oil reservoirs here in
the city of krasnodar Ukraine likely to
be behind it
Russia says it will retaliate after the
attack on the Kremlin
and the retaliation may have already
started these messages for Moscow and
for the Kremlin apparently scrawled on
the back of drones used in a strike on
Ukraine the bombardment is sure to
continue
John Sparks Sky News